(audience applauding)
- Hi everyone, my name is Ruslan Kusov.
I'm cloud COE director at
SoftServe, an AWS Ambassador,
and currently I'm losing my voice.
I have one more presentation today,
but hope everything will be fine,
at least for this presentation.
So today I'm gonna tell you about new era
of platform engineering,
particularly platform
engineering powered by agentic AI
and self-service with agentic AI.
Let me grab my clicker.
First, let me start
with the concept itself,
concept of platform engineering.
I believe most of you may
be familiar with this,
but if not, it all started with DevOps.
Remember this, DevOps,
tools, people, processes,
how we connect those things together,
how we build something
that will be useful for our developers.
And it evolved at some point of time.
It evolves to platform engineering.
So people, they started building
what they call internal
development platform
or self-service platform.
The idea is that if you
have large development team
or teams, like 10 different teams,
you would like to introduce
some set of standards.
Otherwise, you will end up
with a situation when one team,
they are developing their
application using ECS.
Another team, they'll be using EKS.
One team will be using Datadog,
another team will be using
CloudWatch and so on,
and that will introduce
additional operational overheads,
additional costs and so on.
And in order to avoid that,
you would like to standardize.
You would like to build some
sort of like abstraction layer,
the platform that can be
used as a self-service.
So you just follow the standard,
and you just write your code.
Functions well for the developers,
and that's why concept became popular.
And they really mean it,
because we researched different sources.
We worked with multiple customers
of SoftServe's regional
data system integrator.
And we compared our data
with the data from Red Hat.
As you can see on this
slide, 85% of customers,
they are moving towards
platform engineering.
So organizations, they
would like to discover
or they're already using
this platform engineering.
As you can see, 18%, they're advanced,
14, they're just exploring,
and 27, 41, that's like number in between.
Process itself, from our
experience, takes about two years.
So if you're right now
at this exploring stage,
you need about two years to
introduce mature practices
of platform engineering
in your organization.
The problem is that there is
no one-size-fits-all approach.
So simply meaning that
it is a complex product.
It depends on your organizational culture.
It depends on the way
how you are organizing processes
within your organization,
what tools you're already
using in your organization.
As I mentioned previously, it's
the way how to set standards
and not to introduce any new
tools, unnecessary tools.
So how we can approach at that case.
And at SoftServe, we
decided that it makes sense
to build some sort of like framework.
So instead of telling
that you should buy platform
engineering solution,
you should build platform
engineering solution
that will follow all your needs.
So we introduced our own
framework based on experience,
based on our interaction with our clients,
based on feedback that we received
and, of course, in collaboration with AWS.
And that ended up with this concept
that you can see on the screen,
a concept where we have core components,
EKS, ECS, and Lambda,
because we are talking about
microservices architecture
and all other components
that will complement this
microservices architecture
like microservices runtime,
observability components,
security components, CI/CD,
because we need to build continuous,
we need to test them,
we need to deploy.
The storage is databases,
third-party services.
And of course we have this IDP,
Internal Development Portal,
the tool, that will be your interface,
the developer's interface to
interact with this platform.
So again, the idea is that
all what you need to do
is just to design integration interfaces
and understand that in case,
today, you're gonna use HashiCorp Vault
and tomorrow we are gonna
switch to Secrets Manager,
you're not gonna do
anything with your code.
So you just update this
integration interface,
CSI driver for example.
And you will get new
tool securely connected
to your environments,
to your applications.
Pretty cool idea.
As I said,
we call it SoftServe's Adaptive
Modernization Platform,
but it's not a platform, it's framework.
I know things sometimes confuse people,
but we are trying to follow AWS
in naming our services.
So this platform, we
started with blueprint.
So as you can see,
it's all Kubernetes reference architecture
related to EKS blueprints
released a couple of years ago.
We have multi availability zones.
We have cluster components
split by critical components
and worker components.
We have those environments insulated.
We have best practices like
Karpenter instead of Autoscaler
to better manage efficiency
and scaling capabilities of the cluster.
And if we dive deeper,
we'll also introduce
some default components
because again, remember that
not everything can be solved
with a Kubernetes alone.
You should think about
observability, security,
CI/CD and other things.
And as you can see,
we build this framework
considering those other components,
but they are built in the way
that these components can
be easily substituted.
So again, if for example,
you don't want to use
Argo CD for deployments
because currently using Jenkins
and you are absolutely
fine with that Jenkins,
you can proceed with the Jenkins.
But we'll give you a
framework that will tell you
what gaps you have in
platform engineering,
how you can fill these gaps
with our default solution
and also framework
that will show you how to apply
these platform engineering
processes and practices
for your organization.
It worked really well till 2023,
the year when people started
experimenting with AI.
The funny thing in 2023,
that's the fact that
people, a lot of people,
they did not realize that
AI was not something new.
AI was born like 1956
with a small workshop.
It evolved over the years.
And 2023, that was the year of experiments
and year of Gen AI, generative AI.
I believe everyone had
experiments with the ChatGPT,
with chatbots, whatever.
That's like common use cases.
However, that was hype that
distracted people a lot,
and it distracted our
platform engineering practices
as well.
Next year, that was year after hype
when people realized that,
"Okay, so we created a lot of chatbots,
a lot of experiments with Gen AI,
but how we move that to production.
And 2025, we're still not in production.
And you can join my second session
where I will show you some
specific numbers about that.
But 2025, that's a year when we are trying
to identify business value
of AI, Gen AI, Agentic AI,
But we are trying to build a
business case for our customers
in order to move them to this AI era.
Suddenly, we figured it out
that it's very well connected
with the platform engineering use cases.
So SDLC, to be honest, I
was not like surprised,
but that was an honor for me this morning
to participate in this
keynote note from Matt Garman.
And he shared the same idea
that, in terms of SDLC,
it is end-to-end process.
So you cannot just take
an agent for testing,
agent for business, for
planning, for UI design,
because if you take just a single agent
and not going to care about
end-to-end SDLC process,
you will fail.
You will introduce yet another bottleneck.
How it works.
So let's imagine that you
have a life cycle, SDLC cycle,
every two weeks.
You have new release every two weeks.
You introduce testing agents.
So now you don't need two
weeks to test all your code.
You can test it within hours.
But your developers cannot
develop the code within hours.
They still need two weeks
to develop new code.
So you'll be waiting, sitting and waiting
on the code that should be tested.
Deployments, environments
cannot be prepared
in hours or days.
We still need two weeks to
prepare those environments.
So it's instead of improving the process,
you will introduce yet another
bottleneck to that process.
And in order to avoid that,
you need to have this end-to-end solution.
So again, we connected that
with platform engineering.
What if considering this
SDLC as a common case
or one of the best business
cases for organizations
to step up into this era of AI,
Agentic AI, Gen AI and so on,
what if we connect that
with a platform engineering,
one of the most mature cases
that we had previously?
And we decided to extend the idea
of self-service portal with AI.
So that's how we released AIDEEQ,
or AI Driven Enhanced
Engineering with Amazon Queue.
Again, don't pay attention to the names.
We are following AWS best
practices in naming our services.
So we released this idea of
self-service powered by AI.
And as you can see, it all
based on the components
that either available, like
first party agents from Amazon,
Amazon Queue, Amazon Bedrock
agents, AWS Transform.
Pay attention to agents
that AWS releases today,
especially security agent, DevOps agent.
That's something that we
tested in a preview mode,
worked really well as
an extension to this.
The MCP servers,
custom agents, reusable prompts, LLMs.
With LLM, it is the same
situation as with engineers, yes?
So you have two different engineers
with their background,
with their experience.
And if you ask them to do
the same thing for you,
one engineer can spend one hour,
another engineer can spend two hours.
You can get different results.
They will work.
They both will work these results,
but one result will be more
cost effective and scalable,
another one less secure, for example.
And the same with LLM.
That's why it's important
to choose the right LLM
and provide this power
of choice to developers.
So to highlight,
it is yet another iteration
of platform engineering.
So we just introduced
enhancement for the self-service
that brings this AI
capabilities for the developers.
This self-service,
the idea of the self-service
is to introduce a nail gun.
So if you're a constructor,
you build a new house,
of course you can build new house
with just nails and hammer,
that will take like months,
or you can take a nail gun
and use that for the purpose,
for the same purpose of building new house
within a week or less.
The same with the platform engineering.
And a couple of cases,
so real cases before I jump to live demo.
The first case,
that's the case that we implemented
for one of our customers.
That's the case where we
orchestrated this deployment
CI/CD flow with the help of AI,
with the help of MCP servers.
Pretty simple case.
So developer in this case
needs to know only about
programming language.
So I know Java.
I'm gonna run or create
my application in Java,
and that's it.
After that, I will put
commit to repository
and everything else will be done by AI.
So it will detect programming language,
it will create a Dockerfile,
build a container from that Dockerfile,
deploy it to Amazon EKS
using manifest generated by another agent
and will return me a status of deployment.
If everything is okay, I'll
get notification in Slack
that it was successful deployment.
If something is wrong,
I will get notification that it is wrong
and analysis from MCP
servers to CloudWatch and EKS
about potential root cause for
problem with my deployment.
The second use case is pretty similar.
So we here you can see an
example of model that we used.
We use Claude 3.7 Sonnet for that.
The idea is that we build a tool
for validation of
deployments to Kubernetes.
It includes validation of
application components,
it includes validation
of cluster components,
Kubernetes cluster components.
But by the end of that,
customer receives validated
Kubernetes deployments.
And after a production release,
the customer can be sure
that everything was fine
and no issues happened during deployment.
Or, in case of any issues,
that would be a rollback process
with notification of
root cause for that fail.
Well, it works really well
in production environments
and we saved about three
months of time for the customer
by implementing that instead
of rewriting the tool
that they built originally using Golang.
So again, to highlight, we're
not gonna build a product.
It doesn't make any sense.
We built framework.
We don't have any software,
proprietary software,
intellectual property here,
but we do have a framework
that helps to accelerate deployments,
accelerate application development,
application modernization, migration,
increase development productivity.
And this framework follows
all the best practices
for the security, high reliability,
scalability, cost efficiency.
So it's very well aligned
with the well-architected framework.
Now it's time for the demo.
So it's live demo, so apologize
if it's not gonna work,
but I'll do my best.
And this demo about migration,
that's an example of self-service.
Yes, that's an example of self-service
that can be done for a migration.
So let's imagine that I'm
running my data center.
And in this data center, as you can see,
it's connected through VPN.
I have my internal IP address for that.
I can create some stuff here,
add to my to-do list, it'll be added.
So it's well-functioning application.
Pretty simple architecture.
So I have virtual machine
with load balancer,
two virtual machines with application,
and one virtual machine
with a Postgres database.
And I'm gonna move it to AWS Cloud.
So I'm gonna use benefits
of AWS Transform service.
That's a service that
allows me to run assessment,
gets dependency mapping,
verify my service,
runs through right-sizing exercise.
But Transform works
well for lift and shift.
Unfortunately lift and shift,
that's a strategy for lazy migration.
So that's the best strategy
to introduce technical debt,
but not the best strategy
to run in the long term
or in a long time.
With that customers,
they prefer to find a
way how to modernize,
how to introduce replatforming
and re-architecture at the beginning.
So is it possible to perform
replatforming, re-architecture,
with the cost of lift and shift?
And with this demo, I will show you that,
yes, it's possible.
And that's because of the self-service
that we provided to our developers.
So again, on the left hand side,
that's architecture that I have right now.
On the right hand side,
that's something that I'm gonna build.
Load balancer instead of virtual machine.
I'm gonna use managed service RDS
with the primary and replica
set up, multi-AZ deployment,
and my application
converted to containers,
containerized and deployed to EKS.
So application itself,
that's Java application, as you can see.
And what we built, we built this agent.
This is a fancy web UI that I added
for the purpose of this demo.
But this is the agent
that can be integrated
to ID of your choice.
So Visual Code Studio, whatever
else that you're gonna use,
it can be easily integrated.
And what I'm gonna do, I'm
gonna show you that I have my,
and that's what I'm talking about.
So I have my servers,
and I have my servers
discovered by Transform.
Thanks god I saved this file earlier,
so probably I'll skip this
part with AWS Console,
so you should trust me.
But that's a file generated
by AWS Transform agent.
So with AWS Transform, what I did,
I used Discovery tool.
So we can read about this Discovery tool
to get this CSV file.
So this CSV file identified instances,
their IP addresses, and roles,
client database, client load balancer.
According to that, according to that,
again, I'm sorry, but I need
to log in again to my console
so I'm not gonna show you visualization,
but we can chat offline
after this presentation.
Back to this tool that we built,
this agent that we built
for the modernization.
And all of what we need to do
is just download our files,
the CSV file and WAR artifacts
for this Java application
to S3 bucket.
That's pretty much it.
Everything else is just to push
this button, Start Analysis.
And under the hood,
that's implementation
of this self-service.
So particular version,
Java Containerization
Agent of that self-service,
the use case, developer
who is operating on-prem,
but going to migrate to the cloud
with zero knowledge of the cloud itself,
with zero knowledge of cloud services.
But I'm gonna migrate my application
to reference architecture
with the containers,
with the load balancer,
with RDS managed service,
and I'm gonna use AI for that.
I'm gonna use these
capabilities of self-service
connected with AWS Transform.
So we're gonna wait
for a couple of seconds
just to have it fully generated.
And I will show you what
this tool actually creates
and how it can be used for the next steps.
So meanwhile, just a reminder
that we are going from
this legacy lift and shift
to this modernized environment.
Yeah, still no access.
I actually like this fact of live demo,
because it shows you
real time that is needed
to create this conversion,
to generate all the files,
generate all the manifest,
deployment Dockerfile,
and actually have something
that can be easily deployed
to a live environment.
So technically, within this live demo,
you are just watching the
process of real migration
for this simple application.
And in order to understand
what does it mean for you,
for your cases,
if you have large migration,
planning to migrate 1000 VMs,
all what you need to do
is just multiply that
by 100 or 1000
to understand how much time you
need for that modernization.
Okay? So generating recommendations.
I hope it will be here soon.
Yeah, so meanwhile, again,
unfortunately I cannot
show you what's going on,
but AWS Transform has
integration with Migration Hub.
It will be deprecated,
service itself will be deprecated.
However, right now through
this Migration Hub,
you can see the list of servers,
you can see dependencies.
So this network map dependencies,
and this file that's actually exports
from that Transform Discovery tool.
So that's pretty much what you can use.
And you can see in a Migration
Hub planning your migration.
But again, reminder
that Transform supports
just lift and shift
migration, nothing else.
Okay, live demo.
Yeah, running a bit late.
Probably like people
using Bedrock proactively,
because under the hoods,
we are using Bedrock, we are using API.
We are using connection to
Bedrock and predefined prompts.
So we defined LLM.
We build this custom agents,
custom entities, and we predefined prompts
that can be used in
order to run this request
and create results
that will help me to
modernize my application.
Wrapping up.
So by the end of this demo,
I hope, once I'm done
with my presentation,
we can chat offline.
By the end of this demo, you
will have generated YAML file,
Dockerfile,
Dockerfile, that will help
you to deploy application,
YAML file, that will help you
to apply and deploy this
application to Kubernetes cluster.
And you will have step-by-step instruction
how to move your database.
So snapshot, that should be taken first.
Oh yeah, finally.
So as I said, it took more time.
So it's like results of the analysis
with a old deployment
roadmap, preparation step,
application containerization
step, Kubernetes deployments,
load balancer configuration,
database migration,
validation testing and details.
So as you can see, Dockerfile
for your application,
build command for that Dockerfile.
Kubernetes deployments,
Kubernetes services,
ConfigMap, variables,
and configuration for other resources,
including CDK code for infrastructure,
the code for load balancer
and CDK for database service.
With that, coming back to my presentation,
that was an example of self-service
that we introduced for our customers.
And for our developers,
it accelerated a lot
our migration practices
and modernization practices.
So in average,
we can see two to three times improvements
in terms of time needed for
migration and modernization.
And last but not least, it
is the way to do migration
with replatforming and
re-architecture strategy
instead of lift and shift
and instead of introducing
this technical debt,
and with a almost zero cloud knowledge,
so the way of proper use or
use case for self-service.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)